the thing about Des santis is he's
supposed to be the man right but he's
not the man yeah so imagine you're the
quarterback of a football team like
nobody's really heard you talk nobody's
hung out with you yeah you just
transferred from another school and you
just kill it on the field and then like
the first party you're like this
driveway is not
regulation it's weird and you're like
you know what like dude what is this guy
and he's like this driveway is weird
like I when I grew up by a circular
driveway and people would park because
the thing with this driveway is it's
like a semicircle but how do you get out
and you'd go dude shut up what the
wrong with you why are you
talking about driveways you're supposed
to be like the man